s'agit d'un salon international avec 50
pays de l'amérique et de la caraïbe qui
sont présents ou représentés
officiellement la martinique participent
à la foire et à l'exposition donc le
côté foire expo et il ya également des
conférences et on nous a demandés on m'a
demandé on va solliciter pour présenter
la martinique va se parer à ce plateau
de 50 pays y compris les nord les
nord-américains pour connaître mieux la
martinique son attractivité ses points
forts également les opportunités
d'investir en martinique dans les
différents secteurs concernés est une
chance pour la martinique puisque on a
on a besoin d'une meilleure visibilité
en ce moment les américains
particulièrement ne conçoivent pas
réellement ce que nous sommes c'est à
dire faisant partie du bassin caribéen
mais également rattachée à la france et
faisant partie de l'europe
et justement nous sommes là pour leur
présenter tous les avantages et les
atouts 107 id qui permet de
d'accompagner par les désinvestissements
les subventions européennes des actes
des actions fortes et qui également très
sécurisant puisqu'elle est rattachée à
la monnaie forte qu'elle euros et à une
stabilité financière et politique que
représente la france cette manifestation
est très grande importance puisque ça
permet à la martinique de se faire
connaître de se donner une visibilité
par rapport à 50 pays qui participent à
cet événement d'amérique et des caraïbes
absolument notre expertise de
d'accompagnateurs d'entreprise depuis
huit ans nous faisons ce type 2
deux missions collectives à l'export
principalement ciblé sur la floride du
sud dans le cadre de ces événements et
on est des entreprises à se faire
connaître à se présenter à trouver des
opportunités de marché de partenaires
sur ces zones
sur le terrain il ya déjà un travail de
recherche et de prospection de
partenaires que notre association
sexuelle même d'inventaire des
des opportunités possibles et ensuite de
préparation de des entreprises à
l'export
on prépare les outils les visuels des
supports de communication etc de façon à
ce que tout soit au format attendu par
nos interlocuteurs
quels sont les contributions des impôts
alors des contributions c'est dans une
présentation dans différents domaines on
a aussi bien des domaines
de l'artisanat de la mode des saveurs de
digital que ces entreprises ont des
choses à présenter et à ce moment là
nous on va les aider justement à
valoriser ses points forts et les aider
à se faire connaître sur le marché de
façon pertinente alors cette ouverture
et d'une connaissance effectivement que
nous avons de la floride et soins
d'implantation parce que moi pour
personnellement ça fait 20 ans que je
j'interviens sur la floride du sud
connecté à la martinique et la
guadeloupe sur des activités et là on
profite de ce
de cette expérience pour aider nos
entreprises à avancer